[Music]
the year
1974 the location
outer space between venus and mercury
[Music]
nasa's mariner 10 probe had a serious
problem
because of some unplanned maneuvers they
were running
much lower on propellant than expected
and in order to maintain
control of the spacecraft nasa had to
come up with a workaround
if they didn't do something quickly the
probe could miss mercury altogether
that's when engineers came up with an
ingenious plan
and what they ended up doing was using
the
solar panels of the spacecraft and just
angling those panels with respect to the
sun
and letting sunlight pressure move and
position the spacecraft as needed
[Music]
and it worked mariner 10 became the
first probe to fly by mercury
giving humans the first close-up images
of the planet
this close call showed that solar
pressure could be used to keep a probe
on course
just like a sailboat uses the wind
so nasa was able to successfully sail
with mariner 10 even though that was not
part of the original mission design
solar sailing uses an existing almost
limitless energy supply from the sun
if you have a light on right now or in
the sunlight
you might be surprised to know that that
light is pushing you
well believe it or not sunlight actually
does exert a force on us
if you go outside on a bright sunny day
you're probably feeling the equivalent
of
maybe the same amount of force as a very
light feather might exert resting in the
palm of your hand
it's not very much and we don't even
notice it because
even the slightest breezes will easily
overwhelm our sense of being pushed
but in space it's a very different story
because there is no ground
to anchor yourself against there is no
other wind or breezes or other forces
acting on you
so ever so slowly but surely
that sunlight pressure will build up and
will very gradually
accelerate you away
[Music]
solar sailing was first written about by
johannes kepler in 1610
thought a space sail might one day
capture sunlight the way a boat sail
catches the wind
although he didn't fully understand the
mechanism to make this a reality
it was later theorized by physicist
james clerk maxwell
who mathematically showed that sunlight
carries momentum that exerts pressure on
objects
if you get in the near vacuum of space
and you have a low mass
low weight object and a shiny reflective
sail that the light can bounce off of
you can actually use it to propel a
spacecraft or at least that's the theory
solar sailing offers a possible solution
to one of the largest obstacles facing
missions today
a limited fuel supply once you use up
all of your propellant
you've got nothing else to push with and
that's a fundamental limitation of
rockets
but with successful solar sailing
demonstration missions by the japanese
aerospace exploration agency
nasa and most recently the planetary
society
missions could now be longer cheaper
quicker
and go further out into space than ever
before
it really opens up the solar system for
exploration on a scale
that we cannot come close to with our
current technology
astronomers sometimes say that space is
curved
people like carl sagan the co-founder of
the planetary society
saw the potential it had for future
missions now what would this do
well it takes you to where you want to
go so one mission that's being talked
about is to
rendezvous with halley's comet and i've
always wanted to do that
he would inspire a generation to make
his dream a reality years after his
death
but the planetary society's first solar
sail cosmos one
never made it into orbit after a rocket
failure in 2005.
it was the japanese aerospace
exploration agency's ikeros that became
the first to demonstrate solar sailing
in 2010
and a year later nasa's nano sale d did
the same in low earth orbit
but it's the development of even more
recent technologies that are starting to
enable real missions
the key enabling technology behind solar
sailing isn't so much
the sale it's making the payload
as small and lightweight as possible and
in recent years we've developed
what's called cubesat technology we even
have what's called nanosat technology
these are tiny satellites that can
weigh less than a kilogram and contain
all of the electronics
necessary to conduct a mission
everything from your avionics
your communication attitude control
navigation
everything all baked onto a few
chips of silicon so these cubesats
coupled with a solar sail
make for a very effective yet very low
cost payload
this combination of solar sailing and
lightweight craft when used together
could make space exploration cheaper and
more accessible to everyone
and the planetary society set out to
prove that it could be a practical
option
in 2019 the super lightweight cubesat
the size of a loaf of bread
called lightsail 2 launched aboard the
spacex falcon heavy
so lightsail 2 launched as a
cubesat that was this size this is a
one-to-one cardboard
version and once it got in orbit
it opened up solar panels exposing
inside
the sail material and some of the
instrumentation the cameras
then we deployed the sail which is about
the size of a boxing ring
32 square meters and deployed these four
triangular sails
that come out of the loaf of bread
the material of the sail itself is
mylar so like mylar balloons but
actually thinner it's about
four microns in width micron being
one millionth of a meter so it's very
thin
and to keep it from ripping it's got so
called rip stops which are
strings that are in a hash pattern
light from the sun which is made up of
photons hit the shiny mylar material
carrying momentum
bouncing off and causing a push
the team then used the momentum wheel to
steer the spacecraft
lightsail 2 was the first ever mission
to successfully maneuver in space using
solar sailing
the main goal with light cell 2 was to
demonstrate controlled solar sailing in
a small
spacecraft specifically cubesat and we
did accomplish that
and it's still sailing but this is only
the beginning
in the next few years nasa's artemis 1
will head to the moon
and on board will be a solar sailing
mission called the near earth asteroid
scout or nia scout
once in space it will separate from
artemis and travel to an asteroid within
three years after its launch
we actually have an agreement with nasa
so we're working directly with their
near-earth asteroid scout solar sail
mission
and working together to feed forward
what we're learning
but solar sailing isn't only confined to
the inner solar system where there's
plenty of sunlight
quite the opposite it could offer the
best way to reach the outer solar system
and beyond
but it will need to improve from its
current technology
one of the main disadvantages with
current solar sail designs
is that they are monolithic which means
that you ultimately have to
pitch roll and yaw the entire sale
but if you can break the sail up into
component parts
you can then individually articulate
each of those components and you can
gain a lot more maneuverability
and that's what a company called
explorer are working on
with their sun vein concept sun vein
takes a
really large sail area and breaks it up
into
six or eight individual veins the veins
can then be independently articulated
that would make sunbane a highly
maneuverable sale
the advantages of high maneuverability
mean that you can
reach a target destination that much
faster
because you can plot a more direct and
more efficient
course to get you from point a to point
b
the sun vein will tack inward toward the
sun like a sailboat tacking into the
wind
and then turn its veins toward the sun
for maximum acceleration
the technology demonstration which is
still in its initial planning stages
aims to reach speeds of 5 to 8
astronomical units or
au per year 1au being the average
distance from the earth to the sun
that will make the sun vein
demonstration mission the fastest
man-made probe
ever launched reaching jupiter in less
than a year
all without a drop of fuel
but considering the great distances of
space it will need to go even faster
and fly even closer to the sun to
accomplish the kind of deep space
missions scientists are hoping to
achieve
but so far the technology isn't there
well the temperatures in that
environment are going to be extremely
high so you need
very lightweight yet very durable
materials so some advanced materials
that might come along might be something
like
silicon nitride or silica sales
these materials don't yet exist but
there are companies that are working on
developing them
another limitation is that solar sails
won't easily be able to carry anything
heavy
like a person to propel
a larger payload say a crude
payload well you're going to need a
very large sail and a lot of time to
get to a sufficient enough speed
unless of course you want to send your
crew into a
sundive maneuver but that might not be
very good for their health
but for smaller craft the possibilities
are limitless
the most ambitious mission using solar
sails even involves visiting another
solar system
and would allow us to reach our nearest
star system alpha centauri in just
20 years it's called
breakthrough star shot so starshot
envisions
using an array of terawatt lasers
concentrating their light on a tiny
sailcraft
that weighs less than one gram in that
one gram package
contains the sail a spacecraft a camera
a transmission antenna everything all
hyper miniaturized
the nano sails would accelerate at
something like 10 percent the speed of
light
and potentially reach out for centauri
in about
20 years while the technology is nowhere
near making breakthrough starch out a
reality
solar sailing is entering its next phase
missions that were once huge endeavors
because of the cost and size
will soon be able to launch as secondary
payloads piggybacking off other missions
that means visiting asteroids moons of
the outer planets
or even interstellar objects that enter
our solar system
could be achieved much more easily
you get an infinite amount of sunlight
that is never ending
so you leave your fuel on the ground and
you just continue to sail
so it's not like sailing by sunlight is
going to replace chemical rockets
but solar sailing will allow us to do
more than what we can do with chemical
rockets alone
this technology is important for future
missions because it's
it's an enabling technology it enables
you
to do missions with solar weather
monitoring that you couldn't do
otherwise poles sitting on
planets that you couldn't do otherwise
doing multiple encounters and having a
flexibility to adapt
that that you couldn't do otherwise and
someday maybe doing interstellar
missions
which you couldn't do otherwise
you